all right so let's work on uh
tying up the guy preoccupying the guy
okay so um we're not gonna have him
just begin our level where he's postured
up
okay so he's gonna be down for now
in this position okay uh
the first one i'm gonna do is come up
and just hook his head so i'm gonna take
this
on the palm grip so he'll try to stand
up
nope your head posture up and you'll
feel my weight you see that
okay then the next one i'm gonna come in
and get the overhook over here okay if
you want to go
palm the palm again you can you can't
just hold he'll try to posture up
then i'll do it on the other side i'll
come in
and boom the posture up
okay so again the drill one
the posture up move
boom he'll posture up
and i'll change head boom
he'll posture up okay next one
i'm going to come around
inside the arm this way
here then outside the arm
here inhale posture so let me simplify
one your posture okay then
here he'll posture then i'll do it on
the other side
boom hill posture
okay then head
over hook inhale posture
then either side
overhook the posture one more time
head boom head in under
posture head and underhook
posture head
over hook head
over hook okay so
as as i'm doing this i'm not uh
squeezing his body that's gonna fatigue
me out
the guard is really my legs are in front
of his hips
okay uh this
when i'm closing here it's more that my
abdominals are being used
as opposed to my hamstrings and
to keep me close to him and the same
thing goes with all these grips so
i i want to secure them because i don't
want to burn my biceps out but i don't
want to secure them when i'm burning i'm
burning my biceps out
so i'm staying close to him not
necessarily this pulling them okay
and then my center is alive
so my center is up as i go to move
i move and i use my legs to help me move
boom then then i can come in back with
my body
okay here now i'm going to do the same
thing
reverse it boom
over here my legs help me move boom
back in reverse
over boom
move my body move my body
boom
boom next one back up
here one two
here so i'm gonna head
wrist elbow and he'll posture
same thing and then i'll go to the other
side
head wrist elbow
and here inhale posture so again
head head and under hook
head and underhook headed over hook
head and over up
boom here
here posture okay add that
so uh when i control his head don't come
down here by
uh the top of his spine you want to be
in that mastoid
area so if i'm back here and he stands
up you see he's got leverage
well i'm gonna hold his head down he
goes
so you want to get that to work against
him
and then when you're going in these over
and under hooks
don't come and get the arm try to get
the shoulder
okay you want you want these moves are
to make him
move okay so he has to move less to get
out of this
then he has to move to get out of here
and so the same thing
on the uh overhook not down here he
doesn't have to move much
try to get it up here where you're
getting that shoulder
and when you're over here hooking the
head again don't come down on the back
be up so that his neck is working
against him
okay whether i'm here or here i'm
keeping that head working against him
all right so next drill
he's going to throw strikes at me okay
boom both hands boom and i'm just going
to cover
up and move keep going keep covering
boom
[Music]
going in the direction of the strike if
he throws straight strikes
i'll try to get to the outside of it if
he's throwing the inside doesn't matter
i'll move with the strike just like
mandinsky
so he comes boom
boom
boom not reaching
not reaching not reaching covering up
and moving
using my legs to control him
okay good reason for the closed guard
versus the open part
when he go when he goes to punch me i
can use that guard
and to create my angle deviation he goes
again
same thing i'm using that i'm not so
much
worried about my half my hands are
redundant
like that
okay next drill i'm going to do a
combination
of that last drill and then he goes
so that's the last one he goes and i'm
going to combine it with the first row
so
he goes boom he goes i
follow him into that so
i'm not going to sit here deviate
deviate and then try to get that
i'm going to deviate follow him into it
and then get it then he's going to test
wiggle out let me throw some more
punches
then we'll start over
you'll just see which ones you get
it's his job to get out but i'll let him
out
okay okay so he's going
i'm deviating i got the trap got the
trap
um let's say i'm here
or let's change it okay i'm here
i have the head i have to watch out
i have to feel what that hand is doing
so this is not a wrestling match it's
just a drill right now
i don't want him punching me in the ribs
okay or
stabbing me in the ribs so as i go
here and he's i feel that arm going you
see how
i feel that gap up so again
we're here i don't want him punching me
boom boom
boom i don't want him stabbing me so
when i got here
and he goes to move that arm i fill that
gap up
okay and that's how you'll find that
other that other one like that
so if you're the training partner you
get here you're going to
get out i'll reset the drill
boom and when he moves whatever hand i
don't have
go that's the hand i'm going to blend
with okay
that's the hand i blend he tries to move
i'll reset the drill home he goes
i'm sticking to him
i'm always looking for the other hand
what the other hand is doing
let's set free dude
hey i'm work as i work as i get to be a
better partner
he gets better so i'm gonna stay relaxed
and i'm looking for where i can punch
him he's looking for where he
he doesn't get hit
so
why don't you get off the ground like
instead of a medieval virgin
and engage there you go
good kind of a lot there you go use your
legs for balance
so you're burning out that bicep good
fine look instead of clashing go around
it go inside of it
nope inside
stop inside and around where there's no
energy
take away that energy go inside around
there you go
good use your leg you're just using your
arms use your legs relax it
hook the neck good
relax
good follow it up good not at the
shoulder at the elbow
good that's it trap the shoulder
there you go come up that's it
good get in get
good well you're panicking like high
heel room
try to relax look how slow i'm going
good i secure your grips
good relax come up more to me rather
than me pull you down
and good
then you got to reset the drill dude
get your guard up find the trap here it
comes back
follow it up trap good
this is a waste of energy waste the
energy
right here good bring your knee up
good good knee in the elbow try to relax
tighten up knee on hip
good then reset the drill boom
guard deviate good use your legs good
there you go
secure your grip on something there you
go
good good feel it good
good that's it good get in the elbow not
the shoulder
elbow there you go okay all right